il faut arrêter d'armée l'Ukraine
mais moi je pense qu'il faut
effectivement arrêter d'armée l'Ukraine
parce qu'il est temps de faire la paix
et d'arrêter ce conflit vous savez avant
de conflit en Ukraine il y avait des
accords de minskins dans la France était
garant l'Allemagne était également
garant de ses accords et on n'a pas aidé
à respecter ces accords on a continué à
aider à financer malgré le non respect
des accords c'est quoi les accords de
risque les accords de misk c'était de
dire que petit un les les les combats
allez s'arrêter en fait au niveau du
d'en bas les Russes qui ont commencé ces
combats ils vont rester sur les
territoires qu'ils ont occupé
on va juste parler de petite question
qui a attaqué le crâne le 24 février
c'est l'Ukraine ou c'est la Russie mais
c'est l'Ukraine ou c'est la Russie
octobre ou la Russie et je vais vous
donner un autre exemple
laissez-le répondre vous vous rappelez
Zidane il a donné un coup de boule à
d'accord vous rappelez et finalement il
a eu un carton rouge mais tout le monde
a trouvé que c'était génial il avait été
provoqué provoqué provoquer et on en a
fait un duo et il est resté parce que le
marketing a décidé que le coup de boule
de Zidane c'était pas mal alors que
quand les États-Unis attaquent les
États-Unis et l'OTAN attaquent la
Yougoslavie là le marketing dit c'est
génial il faut bombarder il fallait
rayer les gens avec la vous avez vu les
différences d'images entre Bagdad
puisqu'on était tous devant nos télés à
regarder
quelle est la liaison avec l'Ukraine
Poutine a attaqué
le prénom ne cherchez pas ne cherchez
pas les excuses ma Poutine vous avez eu
hier le vote on a changé il y a quatre
il y a quatre personnes qui ont soutenu
il y a quatre étapes
qui ont soutenu le Poutine Corée du Nord
il y a la le Russie Nicaragua et la
série
du côté et la Russie non non non
et qui correspondent à plus de la moitié
de l'humanité et s'abstenir quand il y a
les pressions diplomatiques qui sont
exactement chacun de ces pays-là sur les
chiens
il y en a plein qui se sont abstenus
aussi il y a 25 États oui c'est vrai que
ce soit absolu donc c'est quand même 35
35 ouais donc c'est quand même énorme
voilà juste aujourd'hui
est-ce que la France prend un risque en
continuant d'armer l'Ukraine parce qu'on
voit de plus en plus de français dans
les rues je vous le dis le français qui
me parle il me disent attention nous ça
commence à nous gonfler je dis je me
fais le porte-parole de ce que je vois
sur les réseaux de porte-parole de ce
que mes viennent me dire les Français
quand je les croise dans la rue parce
que vous connaissez très bien le
problème mais là je parle des Français
les Français qui disent tous les jours
qui n'ont pas d'essence actuellement
qui sont dans une galère monstre qui
voit l'hiver arriver et qui se disent on
est on devait déjà être dans la merde
est-ce qu'on va pas être encore plus
dans la merde et qui se pose beaucoup de
questions donc là la question elle est
là on a vu le président à préciser la
dernière fois il a bien fait de le faire
de dire l'essence ça n'a rien à voir
avec l'Ukraine ouais il a bien fait de
le faire parce qu'il y a plein de gens
au départ qui disent c'est la guerre en
Ukraine qui faisait qu'on avait pas
descendre donc il a bien fait de le
préciser le président le président parce
qu'on sait on savait plus mais c'est
vrai que voilà est-ce que ça peut nous
retomber dessus on n'est pas français
qui se disent est-ce que ça va nous
retomber dessus elle est vraiment pour
résumer tu entends les mêmes choses que
moi non seulement je l'entends mais moi
je le pense j'ai fait comme tout le
monde au mois de mars allez souvent
l'Ukraine il y a pas de problème avril
mais finit l'abondance ok on a foi avec
l'Ukraine mais combien de temps elle va
durer cette guerre parce que ok la
pénurie c'est pas c'est pas l'Ukraine
mais les deux euro 10 c'est l'Ukraine et
nous avons dit non c'est assez le prix
de l'essence qu'augmenter il faut
m'expliquer comment c'est parti de de
connaissance 65 % c'est les taxes déjà
ça n'a rien à voir si vous faites 65% du
prix ce sont des taxes avant le prêt le
prix du le prix de pas rentrer là-dedans
c'est le pétrole il était à 100 dollars
on payait on payait le gasoil en euro 30
arrêtez il y avait quand même 60 % de
taxes il y a les pays de l'OPE qui se
sont réunis il y a une semaine que vous
décidez d'arrêter la production de de 1
million par jour de baril c'est-à-dire
que de d'augmenter artificiellement le
prix de pétrole vous êtes bien armé
l'Ukraine pour venir
armer l'Ukraine mais un moment donné à
un moment donné vous avez entendu vous
avez entendu ce que ça on veut pas payer
l'électricité plus cher on peut pas
payer d'essence plus cher on veut pas
mais c'est nous dire qu'il faut mettre
le chauffage à 17 à 18 à 19 on veut
rester libre